how incorrect uncharacteristic
of one of your reputation show
immediately reminds me that werner
herzog is no longer going to be playing
a character in it and for making me sad
it gets a sin a bunch of logos that tell
me that i'm watching a star wars
property in case i already
didn't know yo i know we need to see
this wretched hive of scum and villainy
but can we get on with it this walk is
taking longer than sir lancelot's run-up
to swamp castle
oh look a banksy oh let's get ready
to go
[Music]
also i'm pretty sure this fight sequence
is only here because john favreau has a
boxing ring boner and far be it for me
to criticize another person's boner but
really means
all to the rest of this episode i'm told
you know where to find them
man they sure are able to have this
conversation in hushed tones despite the
raging crowd all around them
cheating these scruffy-looking nerf
herders seriously try to get into a
fistfight with a [ __ ] mandalorian
despite seeing him ice all those
henchmen seconds ago
also why would anyone punch mando in his
helmet why would anyone punch anyone's
helmet it's a [ __ ] helmet
i know mando has the armor and has a few
weapons but in the previous episodes i
don't recall him being [ __ ] inspector
gadget
i've spent much time on tatooine i've
never seen a mandalorian there
i feel like we've all spent way too much
time on tatooine in this franchise
there's a ton of world out there left to
explore but yeah let's go back to luke's
boring planet again
cut me down that wasn't part of the deal
no but you did say i promise you will
not die by my hand
and i'm pretty sure that was your hand
that fired the blaster and allowed all
the wild mutts to come kill gorkuresh
what the [ __ ] is up with the score
sounds more like the ending to jingle
all the way than an episode of the
mandalorian
sorry gang come on you know he doesn't
like droids
i'm sure pelly motto might recall
mando's dislike of droids but they've
only met once
and she's acting like this is a lifetime
of experiences they share together
well so he likes droids now will you
hurt him
give it a once-over just because ig-11
sacrificed itself in the previous
episode mando's cool with all
droids now it's like me meeting mark
cuban and deciding all rich white men
are okay
i just can't get good help anymore i
don't even know who to complain
to i love amy sedaris and i appreciate
the humor in this episode i also think
that these characters
wouldn't talk like this sorry i think
the show is trying to jam in hokey
dialogue as a throwback but the worst
part of those classic movies was the
hokie dialogue
you got mos eisley most espa an upper on
this region
most pell go yeah but what happened to
most deaf i miss that guy much more than
most pell go
i have to say this is so like an old
school western that i have to take a sin
off
it's comforting and exciting and
suspenseful all at the same time and for
capturing that classic feeling remove
the sin
but also these townsfolk are totally
giving away the fact that their marshal
has mando armor
if they'd just gone about their business
he probably would have moved on and not
caused any trouble these town folks are
dicks to their leadership man
considering mando keeps telling everyone
he has been quested to take care of the
child
he sure does just leave it behind a lot
where it could easily be kidnapped or
killed why wouldn't he just left it with
pelly motto
she's taken good care of it in the past
[Music]
okay i understand the homage to westerns
but did that sound like actual [ __ ]
spurs
play it again ain't nobody spurs on that
costume man if you're gonna go this over
the top just give him a poncho and a
cigar for
sake cue fanboys orgasms
now i figure only one of us walking out
of here
but then i see the little guy and i
think
maybe i picked you wrong assumptions
around here
i'm the one who tells folks what to do
around here i'm the one tells folks to
do cliche
take it off and do it nice and slow all
sexy like
isn't it about the time that the
bartender crawls beneath the counter i
mean he's pretty much directly in the
line of fire
it's really nice of this underground
creature to make its way through town in
a straight path and right through the
center so as not to destroy any of the
buildings
also show does not have a no banthas
were harmed during this production
warning
comparisons the town was on its last
legs
it started after we got news of the
death star blowing up the second one
that is
celebrating the deaths of all those
innocent independent contractors
also what is up with this episode having
impossible conversations in extremely
loud environments
and then i was saying wait he just
noticed this
now how did he not see that giant
automobile in the distance a long time
ago
my treasure bought me more than a full
water skin
it bought my freedom but only because
the miners went to the stormtrooper
school of aiming at things and didn't
shoot you in your arm
neck stomach or legs timothy bobafant
also i don't know what's more surprising
that the jawas had mandalorian armor
or that they had a helmet that fit cobb
vance so perfectly what am i supposed to
do with this
you drink it it stinks hey the tuscan
raiders have their own version of malort
i bet there's a subreddit devoted to
raider face
how do we kill it if he could speak
english while making the hand gestures
and they still understood what he was
saying
then what were all the grunts about but
also the fact that the show took the
time to hire a deaf actor to create this
tuscan sign language for raider nation
is pretty cool and worthy of a sin off
i say it lives in there didn't cobb
already know that though he brought
mando all the way out here didn't he
this here is a mandalorian you know what
that means
oh we've heard the stories then you know
how good they are at killing
but he doesn't because he just said he's
only heard stories maybe do a little
more listening discount raylen gibbons
the crepe dragon has been peeling off
our pack animals and sometimes taking
our mining hall with it
i know this is a bothersome phenomenon
but it doesn't sound like the dragon has
been killing anyone in the town
in fact the greater threat to the
livelihoods of this town are the tuscan
raiders themselves so why is cobb
willing to risk his greatest asset in
combat to get rid of this
annoyance sure mando could kill him but
he's risking the entire town
to combat something that isn't really
the biggest threat to his community
this tuscan raiders meets the people of
most pell go scene goes on for some time
what are you trying to blow the whole
place up nice wouldn't be a traditional
western tv episode without a protagonist
fight amongst themselves before the
final act of the show cliche
cheese and crackers there's more
unnecessary walking in this episode than
in the entirety of the lord of the rings
franchise
sure now is the best time to take a
drink of this foul juice does he even
know if it's nutritious or
up like peyote the tuscan say the belly
is the only weak spot
i guess that would be a fair assumption
but since they've never killed one of
these how do they know that
sand people yell at this dragon to wake
him up when he's peacefully hibernating
and did i miss who the actual antagonist
is here
this [ __ ] plan i'm gonna hit it no
wait we only have one shot
then maybe it would have been a good
idea to set the chargers closer to the
entrance of the cave
by the way nice job helping with this
[ __ ] operation mr being who could
probably in this evil bastard by waving
your hands a few times before multiple
people were killed
i don't think it's dead well not with
that attitude it's not let's get after
it
yes after we've stood on the sidelines
while this futile explosive trick was
tried and failed
we can do it there he is yeah but how
how did it get from the top of the
mountain to here without any one of you
knowing
i don't know the best car armor is
impervious to the dragon goo and he
survived being swallowed by that
and this explosive work even though the
other one didn't and i guess this is a
long-winded way of saying
mando survives this hey what a twist
it's
that guy and yeah yeah i know that
everyone thinks it's boba fett because
of the actor or whatever but some of us
that just watch this show haven't
witnessed every single [ __ ] piece of
star wars history multiple times so this
isn't a twist to us
it's just confusion about why i'm
watching this random bald guy look at
the sunsets
oh johnny i apologize i forgot you were
there
you may go now do you hear the ding in
your head when you watch movies
i hear it all the damn time especially
around the holidays and i'm done hiding
my damn dings i'm going to wear them
proudly like a goddamn youtube grinch if
you want to do the same you can grab
this limited edition monstrosity from
our store
mary dingles everyone
you must be crazy i'm crazy you're just
a stupid yeah baby
kill him finish him easy with that face
on me
oops a wet one i hope i didn't
stain my underwear you're making a
terrible mistake i'm not gonna let you
make come on guys
nobody wants this we're supposed to be
professionals
sydney
good people who have traveled from
villages near and far
lend me your ears that's disgusting
[Music]
why am i drippings with fool panned down
from the twin sons
of tatooine after a beat the gloved
mandalorian armor gauntlet of boba fett
grabs onto the sand outside the sarlacc
pit and we realize
that he survived his fall during the
battle at
jabba's palace ship